[Music]
how many times has this happened to you
it's a new year and you're still writing
the old year on all your checks your
existence has become a living nightmare
and it seems like there's only one way
now well now there are two ways
I'm a Vanderbeck founder and creator of
the amazing check correct memory
enhancement system in just four simple
steps your memory will be writing checks
your cast can check
wait a minute into your check will be
step one plenty of water step two get
lots of sleep
step three
undergo a fast and simple brain surgery
of one of my correct certified surgical
centers located near you we just remove
a tiny hunk of your brain the part
that's full of all those frustrating
memories from last year so you don't
really need it anyway how do I know it's
safe because I've tested it on myself
step one physical therapy with your new
memory enhance brain your limbs might
have some remembering to do what no wait
okay reincarnation get reacquainted with
the sweet stuff of your life like family
and language and professional with the
help of one of our behavioral smart guys
step one
doggie doggie working stupid brain I
can't do it mom there's too many words
Oh
step four perfect part is you only need
to follow my check correct memory
enhancement program once a year so I'll
check in with you again next year in
2014 no wait 2015
evander been checked off memory
enhancement system is part of no longer
available
that's her new sponsor that's fantastic
excellent